this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday April 21st I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
a basic feature of iPhones can help
criminals who steal phones to also take
over the digital lives of victims it's
the phone's passcode the four to six
digit sequence users type to unlock
their devices this is something the Wall
Street journal's personal Tech columnist
Joanna Stern and Nicole Nguyen reported
on back in February and since then
people have been reaching out to them
about another iPhone security feature
that thieves are using to take over
accounts this time it's the recovery key
Joanna Stern has a video looking at this
and speaking with one of the victims you
can check that out here on YouTube but
to understand more about how this crime
works and how users can protect
themselves I'm joined Now by Nicole
Nguyen so Nicole we spoke about this
kind of theft where someone's iPhone and
their passcode can be stolen can you
just remind us how this crime works and
what some of the repercussions are
a thief will cozy up to a Target or will
Snoop their passcode from afar and using
that passcode and then stealing the
victim's phone they will then access the
iPhone's passwords and log into banking
apps and use other financial apps such
as PayPal and venmo in order to rack up
fraudulent charges many of these victims
were out socializing at night and these
thieves very cleverly would coerce them
into handing over their phones they
could take a picture and then disabling
the phone so that when it was returned
to the victim or the target they would
have to enter in their passcode again or
they would film them from afar and then
zoom in to the video to see what that
passcode was that that person had
entered before stealing their phone
so now you're reporting that for some
victims of this crime there can be a
bigger issue because of something called
a recovery key can you just first
explain what the recovery key is
so a recovery key is an apple design
security setting that was initially
intended to protect people so if you
forget your password or you lose your
password Apple has this password reset
flow at iforgot.apple.com where you can
enter in your phone number and then you
get a verification code sent to that
phone number and then you can reset your
password without knowing your previous
password
so in this case if your phone number was
hijacked by a criminal through an attack
known as Sim swapping which is pretty
complicated but essentially thieves
coerce the cellular companies to move
your phone number to their own Sim to a
phone that they have in their hand then
the recovery key which is an additional
28 digit code is protective because it
would ask for both the Verification
codes into the phone and this recovery
key that
ideally Only You possess
so there's this recovery key which was
supposed to protect Apple accounts is
being exploited by thieves in order to
lock people out of their apple accounts
permanently so that the thieves can
continue racking up fraudulent charges
without the victim remotely wiping their
device or tracking it down through find
my and the photos
contacts messages lost are just
collateral damage from this crime
user is already using the recovery key
though won't they have that 28 digit
passcode themselves you would think that
but all it takes to generate a new
recovery key or turn one on is that
device passcode the iPhone's passcode is
the most powerful way to access your
online identity if you store a lot of
your data in Apple's iCloud
so that device passcode can change your
Apple ID password without needing the
previous password and it can also turn
on the recovery key or generate a new
recovery key without any sort of
additional credentials
you spoke with some of the victims of
these kinds of crimes can you tell us
about their experience
one victim I spoke to Cameron Devine
he's 24 years old and he went to a bar
in Boston with his friends after a Red
Sox game and his phone was taken and he
thought no problem you know my phone is
locked with a passcode and actually
someone had sent a friend of his
a text saying I am the bar manager and I
have your phone and you can come by the
bar to pick it up tomorrow
well in truth that the text was sent by
the thief and it bought the thief a
little bit more time to rack up
fraudulent charges on Cameron's account
and also turn on the recovery key
so after Camden realized that the bar
did not have his phone
he spent weeks with Apple customer
service trying to get back into his
account and the representatives told him
again and again we cannot let you back
into this account unless you furnish a
recovery key and he didn't know what
that was he definitely had never set it
up because he had never heard of the
recovery key and so he's had an Apple
account since he was a kid and has lost
15 years worth of
photos contacts messages everything he
was even locked out of his own Apple
watch because the thief had booted all
of the trusted devices from his Apple
account and so the Apple watch that was
currently on his wrist that he didn't
know the Apple account password to was
essentially a paperweight what is Apple
saying about this situation
an apple spokesman told us we sympathize
with people who have had this experience
and we take all attacks on our users
very seriously no matter how rare we
work tirelessly every day to protect our
users accounts and data and are always
investigating additional Productions
against emerging threats like this one
why does Apple have the recovery key
system Apple has this recovery key
system because online hacking is very
prevalent the situation that the
recovery key does not protect against is
if your iPhone is stolen and the
passcode is stolen along with it so how
do others in the industry deal with
account recovery account recovery is a
big issue across the industry any tech
company that provides a service has this
problem
Google handles account recovery a little
bit differently
if you're a thief and you've stolen an
iPhone and the passcode you can change
The Trusted phone number you can turn on
the recovery key all sorts of things to
block the actual owner out from the
password reset process Google however
accepts a previously listed recovery
email address or phone number
in it you can use data like a familiar
Wi-Fi network or a familiar location in
order to prove that you are you just for
some context I mean how big a deal is
this potential theft because more than
half of U.S cell phone users have
iPhones
it's hard to know exactly how many
people are affected by this type of
crime but we do know that since
publishing our original story dozens
more victims have reached out to us and
new cities have emerged as hot spots and
that includes Chicago New Orleans and
Boston are there any steps that users
can take to protect themselves from
running into this situation with
potentially having their phone stolen at
their passcode stolen and then not
having access to the recovery key until
Apple makes a change to their policy or
some sort of fix to this setting there's
not much you can do to prevent a thief
from turning on the recovery key but you
can make it harder for them so setting a
complicated passcode and using both
letters and numbers what's called an
alphanumeric passcode is really
important and you can also use parental
controls on yourself you can use screen
time which is Apple's parental controls
system to block account changes on your
iPhone
all right that's our personal Tech
columnist Nicole Nguyen Nicole thanks
for joining us for this conversation
thanks Zoe
and that's it for this week's Tech news
briefing tnb's producer is Julie Chang
we had production assistants from Zoe
Culkin our supervising producer is
Melanie Roy and our executive producer
is Chris sinsley I'm your host Zoe
Thomas thanks for listening and have a
great weekend
[Music]